the day I watched this documentary on
the CrossFit Games and they're just
bring up some of the CrossFit women
they're just so [ __ ] huge and this
guy this Australian guy took third he
was T tested positive for steroids
and the rest of them with their traps a
[ __ ] around them and they were laude
look look and the people like this were
like they were like you know he's a
cheater he's dirty and it's stealing
it's robbing from those of us who are
clean Oh Mike
really let's go there you go there you
go dude that's normal that girl right
there yeah it's that's normal them and
Jessica them just gone drugs are
steroids nothing to take away from
they're still phenomenal but come on
III don't be a hypocrite phenomena at
were late yeah yeah yeah I mean are you
[ __ ] joking me though hilarious who
cares a [ __ ] like yeah of course they do
yeah until your until you're going he's
a piece of [ __ ] he's dirty and you're
like but you have giant abs and what do
you talk about no one sees it like it
makes a zero news yeah cuz we just
assume it's like the dodo be up guys
it's alright
it's like them the Olympia's like no
one's like a well I mean you know yeah
it's the same thing yeah well but they
swear that it's their queen so does
Olympia guys yeah he talked to any of
them they all I can't dude this is
protein and mistake dude yeah there yeah
it's normal it's normal for a woman have
a chin like that yeah and you love that
no that's your style
I'll tell you I do lifestyle Fitness one
on earth to me to eat she's so cute to
me she cut the cutest face on the planet
yeah fat dick no she's very feminine fat
dick in the foot she's very feminine
does she have a five o'clock shadow
she'd go full beard would bring her up
what's her name - its Wu and CrossFit
CrossFit 2017 top female CrossFit
athletes dude how do you have time to
look at this [ __ ] oh it's you know you
look at T to me
yeah that's my girl so cute I mean get a
picture I got Lisa God get the [ __ ] out
no no you're a man now you just buy a
hold on Jun leave that picture
now here's the problem dude I want look
at me I want I can't accept you being I
can't look you in the eye year old gay
man I can't look you're going through a
lot
no I'm now a midlife Crimea not a
picture right now Hall you come out of
the closet Oh give me another picture
Gayle haslund oh let me go accept this
yeah I know I don't care huh
you know what okay look her face she's
very handsome
now listen another one you know what if
you and chin looks [ __ ] I would not
care if that's what's going on hey lucky
in the eye well chin so quiet on the
weekends and you're gone the weekends -
I don't care Joe alright that's it we're
[ __ ] each other no I do not care I
can explain it fine now we're on the
Rings where she's so cute alright now
don't do that don't be mean she's not
very pretty
no you're gaming like muscular girl like
chicks with dicks like muscular girls
but that's a little mad you of the worst
taste in women up chin that's how dear
you alright well I got a little carried
why are you looking at her in full
CrossFit mode I would love to look at
your front see how much time you waste
looking up girls I know you're talking
about lifting weights with dicks number
one number one she looks at black guys
you get chicks with dicks there's a
weird [ __ ] crowd here cat yeah I
forget where I was going with this you
and I are the only no no one's in here
rides in the chicks with dicks Chin's in
to killing people and black dude hey I
was watching up my 90-day fiance and
they went to the I think the Philippines
or maybe it might have been it's
somewhere in Asia apologize but on the
street they have these big eggs and then
she was like ooh you gotta try this this
a black dude from like New York she's
like you have to try this so they crack
open this [ __ ] Jurassic Park
Velociraptor egg she's like this the
biggest thing that they're seeing she
goes
sips green juice out of it and then he
goes what the [ __ ] and she takes the cap
off and there's a straight-up
fetus bird with its [ __ ] feet tucked
up and he's like I'm not eating that
she's like with super disrespectful and
he ate it and he was so sick that's real
that's real it's very popular in the
Philippines as well as Vietnam and I
think Cambodia as well so what is hambo
do what is it what kind of what kind of
egg is it it's a chicken egg the
Filipino term for is below
but they're big yeah it's basically a
unborn fetus in an egg and you boil it
alive you drink the soup and it tastes
like broth and then you pour again oh
that's it that's it oh this is what I
was talking about when I said jungle
Asia versus fancy Asian boys all right I
don't I've had it before I've never ate
the bird I only eat the yolk and drink
the like a little broth inside the bird
dude they eat that yeah I mean you ate
that Jun yeah son of a-- I feel bad for
little birdies cute they do they boil
them alive in there yeah what's the
difference between this and eating
soft-shell crab probably nothing but
softshell when i watch the fear factor
any of those game shows and they eat
weird stuff the physical stuff I would
dominate out [ __ ] on most people when it
comes this I'm telling you I do not have
the mental strength to eat that it's
always said job I will give you a
million dollars and put those gold rims
on your Porsche that you want all you
gotta do is suck this egg I could not do
all you have to do is drink horse semen
or horse urine
do you know that that was one of the
things I know that's what got them
canceled you know what valid and I
understand that's when you jump the
shark if you're gonna drink horse semen
then do the bit but did I think horse
semen then that ring you know I'd rather
I'd rather suck off mr. hands and need
that me I looked at Eileen a pic boiled
baby chicken [ __ ] horse semen or horse
here and horse urine he's not a horse
you're an all day over horse semen
I'll take horse urine all look at that's
disgusting I can't believe you guys do
that oh you don't sound sorry you're
speaking slow bro trip you're like all
right where are you bro oh [ __ ] Nick
your spokes I be just let's roll chin
now [ __ ] go Nick was just telling me
how he plays soccer I play soccer and
then I get injured immediately and then
I stop one play like a men's league on
like Sundays like yeah
bunch of dudes get together and play and
some ladies and it's and it's kind of
fun it's super fun it's not very
competitive it's lovely and then every
time I like [ __ ] up my ankle or you know
is that matter after you jump in the air
and score with your head if you need to
holy let me know bro there you go do you
play goalie no but I'd like them yeah I
bet you could do it if you got good
reaction times you should be fine
it's a big day he's a big kid it's a it
will it's not all the world I'll show ya
I honestly it's all about you know it's
all about just seeing that see in the
field and anticipating
no soccer
you've got to have a panoramic eye you
got to be able to see the whole you know
all of it and and when you do then you
react yeah here being super general
without sports I played sports I know
what soccer is I know what this boy no
no it wasn't a thing I like have you
know no you show that I'm a cool dude
that I play soccer a sportsman I'm a
sportsman well I said to Nick in the
bathroom I go dude you know you're
you're thick I mean you have a horse you
brilliant in the bath mine did Nick
Kroll up and asked about athletic yes
sure weird in the bathroom big guy and
he's like what about the sugar and the
carrot juice are you okay with that you
know I'm not just a lot of sugar in the
carrot juice but I love it really yeah I
love carrot juice here's a little sugar
in it how much how much you guys worried
about sugar
Mercer do I look like a sugar bomb I'll
take my shirt off right yeah I have
psoriasis but I got a great bar right
juice arises from the lack of sugar or
for a move it's good point maybe
increase your sugar intake [ __ ] and you
got sir I have an eczema I've got a
constant eczema but you got a psoriasis
right yeah but my diets solving a lot of
problems I think yeah I don't need
apparently I don't need sugar dairy or
gluten now right but I still drink wine
tonight and I fall off the wagon here
and there yeah you have any health
problems near 40 I'm 40 I Eve I eat like
three to four loaves of bread a day and
I
probably not
have you ever tried to substitute the
white bread yeah I mean I did like you
know ballpark Frank's just said yeah I
don't know Mike Franks by the way I will
straight up be like now I'm making it I
want ballpark shout-out to ballpark shut
up sort of shout out to the ballpark
Frank bun I don't like the Wiener no you
do yes
so I'm with my mother this weekend in
Utah I'm here with my mother show Jim
golfing
shout out to moms and my mom mm-hmm
we're golfing guy guys the guy was with
my mother said I want a frankfurter hot
dog the guy says she's from New York the
guy says all right I go yeah but they
got fillers and the guy goes now it's
grass-fed beef and my mother goes you're
getting a hot dog I go I don't know if
it's good for my skin she goes oh shut
up
yeah oh my and mustard and I ate that
[ __ ] hot ashes and it was the best
thing I've ever had in my life and I'm
and I'm probably better for it yeah I
think if you eat a good clean hot dog as
a health that's a helps and [ __ ]
yeah your body does know the difference
just eat it
yeah something would you put on it you
of them they have a mustard sauerkraut
great and I add a bun great no ketchup
no no really
ketchup my dad one of those I like
grilled onions my dad was super I
remember as its young like he was like
walked into a deli what you were like I
was probably seven in the car and he was
like you want a hot dog as a yeah he's
like what do you want I was like mustard
and ketchup and he's like or I just said
ketchup and he's like he looked at me
disappointed yes it was a I know it's
like in New York that you don't put
ketchup on a hot dog I think that's like
my mother grew up corner Katz deli yeah
so that that was the place yeah and
there's no ketchup there either yeah cuz
I feel like ketchup overwhelms it yes I
think a weakness to the ketchup I want
that set I want I want our and I want
and I want yellow mustard you know one
[ __ ] deli must you don't like the
spicy mustard I'll take a spicy mustard
I just don't what that French is yellow
that I can just [ __ ] you like
highlighter yellow yeah he's from he's
from Aurora though no I'm the same I
like that [ __ ] so how I like my own yeah
yeah
yeah